why is it that some people are more
successful than others why is this and I
looked around me and I saw people
younger than me doing better than me and
they weren't any smarter than me nothing
will make you matter than to see
somebody who's dumber than you who's
doing better than you and you say how
can this idiot be doing so well and I
did something that very few people ever
do I went to the best salespeople and I
said how come you're so successful and
they told me what they were doing and I
did it and I made more sales and when I
got into business I asked managers how
do you manage in a business like this
how do you organize it and they told me
and I did it so one of the greatest
success principles that you'll ever find
is learn from the experts learn from the
people who are already demonstrating the
results that you want to get